[Musique]
rabia et maëlys a dit la verrière et
rêve de faire de la musique
elle commence la deuxième saison du
programme demos et apprennent la flûte
traversière auprès des professionnels de
la philharmonie de paris à travailler la
voix et on a commencé à apprendre de
nouvelles musiques
moi j'aime bien la musique et je rêve de
faire de la musique
[Musique]
comme elle une centaine d'enfants
évinois s'entraîner vendredi 27 octobre
au château de versailles auprès de
professionnels cette commune font partie
de l'orchestré demos on apprendre de
nouvelles choses
on apprend des des notes nouvelle note
l'idée de demos est de s'adresser à des
enfants issus de quartiers politique de
la ville qui a priori aurait pas fait de
musique par ailleurs et de leur donner
un instrument pendant trois ans qu'ils
vont apprendre en groupe donc par petits
groupes de 15 2 fois par semaine
et puis une fois toutes les six semaines
ils vont se réunir en grand orchestre de
100 enfants environ et travaillé toute
l'année un programme musical quatre
heures hebdomadaires de travail pour ces
enfants âgés de 7 à 12 ans au programme
de cette année la bacchanale de camille
saint saëns l' orchestre yvelinois donne
rendez vous en juin pour un concert à la
philharmonie de paris
oh